country superstar mared morris is all
about loving her body specifically her
mom boobs
yeah so marin called out all the prudes
on social media who continue to
criticize her nude photo shoot for
playboy back in
now taking the instagram stories marin
shared a screenshot of one commenter
telling her
quote please dress appropriate to which
she responded respect
for mom boobs
i love that response so much now marin
followed that post with a black and
white topless photo from the shoot
adding
letting all the prudes know women in
country music own their sexuality too
yes continuing the conversation on her
instagram feed uh mirren explained
before i go into the next album era i
did playboy in 2019 and got a lot of
hate at the time but i'm the proudest
that i showed country female sexuality
in its realist form here we are nuanced
we are messy and stretch marked in the
most beautiful way don't sleep on us we
tell your down-home stories in the most
unflinching
gorgeous lane don't
forget it yes i i love it stand up for
yourself the haters be damned i like
that she calls them pruitt's too
i think that's very funny i mean let's
be honest here yes the photos are sexy
and she is a woman that is allowed to be
sexy no matter you know
who thinks it's not appropriate because
she works in country music country music
fans are a little serious about when
their women stray from the typical
values in country music but all the
power to her it's playboy you want to be
a little sexy i say go for it there's
nothing wrong with that
yeah uh
country music is seeing an evolution in
a lot of different ways
um and i think this is one of those
things that's like i like that she takes
it
i mean she's serious in response right
but it's also light-hearted about it too
um
and so that she can you know say
this is not you guys don't have to take
this so seriously plus it's my decision
and this is what women do and we're
strong and we tell the stories i dig it
and she's great can i just say two i'm
of the age where i remember
keith urban's playgirl spread just
saying if you haven't looked it up keith
urban yes that keith urban was in play
girl have a look you'll enjoy it there
you go
you see call out the double standard
right